it's an amazing career you have because
you've gone from once you went from
saturday night live to movies that that
did extremely well you know with f well
farley uh you know yeah tommy boy joe
dirt there's ones that have done better
than others yeah you're right who's the
genius that figured that you two guys
would be good in the first movie who who
the who was lauren was it lauren who
said hey you guys should make a movie
together he said
he told two writers they write a movie
about these guys the way they act around
the office like
farley
has a room with spade and then he
spades like the fake smart one and
farley walks behind him and asks him
questions and then i make fun of him and
then it's sort of like the three stooges
kind of yeah moe was smarter than the
other yeah fake smarter and then uh
but i was always like
uh in awe that he was so good and almost
didn't know it so even in movies like
tommy boy
the only thing i could bring to that is
saying
why don't i'm remembering bits and
pieces he would say over the weeks or
years that were funny and just go this
actually one line we got to work in
because you said it two weeks ago or
fat guy a little coat let's let's try to
put that in the movie somewhere even
though it's so dumb but i think people
think it's funny if we do and little
weird things and
gestures and funny faces we would
because he did him so uh casually that i
would try to log him in my head and go
god that's gonna be great and i didn't
know lorne michaels looked at the two of
you guys and said this will be a great
movie i mean that's brilliant that was a
great call because if you think about it
we never could have pitched
that movie if you went to paramount and
said two guys
drive across ohio and try to sell brake
pads
yeah i mean that's just silly yeah i
mean how long does it take to shoot a
movie like that it was pretty quick but
we shot it during siren live and who
wrote the script uh bonnie and terry
turner and then fred wolfe who i've
worked with a million times since has
done it right he's sort of turned into
my writing partner since but
it was
punched up and then we went to toronto
and we would do
you know snl on saturday we'd fly in a
jet to toronto we'd shoot all sunday
maybe that's what made the movie great
because
you guys you guys don't have to think it
through so much it's like almost like
hey we're in the middle of saturday
night live we gotta go shoot this movie
and you know you don't you don't put too
much energy
in one place getting neurotic right but
then maybe the pressure of that is too
much i don't know you know one time i
got skinnier and he got fatter i know
that for sure yeah
see something's going on
well at least it stays on the screen
yeah
the same weight did you ever watch the
old movies or are the two paintings i
mean they're on so much that
you get
caught up in them and it's sort of sad
and fun because you remember the whole
day of the shoot you remember
one day going uh let's bring a little
clip-on tie and say it's a clip-on and
you go really and then
we go let's just try to put that in
somewhere in the scene because you'd see
the mini sides for the next day and go
this feels a little flat what can we do
that is stupid like housekeeping from
tommy boy
i would do every morning when i came to
his room i'd go housekeeping and he'd go
housekeeping and he goes the [ __ ] out of
here i put that [ __ ] thing on the
door and i go housekeeping he goes god
damn it then he'd open the door and go
oh it's you and then you know i do this
every morning chris when you do that
stuff in real life and it's funny and
then you go to try it on film you don't
know for sure and we were just like left
alone in toronto doing time boys so we'd
wake up and the director and one of the
writers and go can we just try this and
and the director of pete segal was great
because sometimes
because he didn't know us well but
sometimes he'd go i trust you guys if
you think this is funny i go i don't
know but
made us laugh last night and the
carpenter's singing and stuff we do
anyway we go if it done right i think
people will think it's funny too
you